أنا أراه ، ولا عجب أن القطة حصلت على
لساني ، نعم ، هذه بقع ، لقد
حصلت القطة التي يبلغ وزنها 40 رطلاً للتو على مالك جديد ، وسنحاول
معًا برنامجًا لفقدان الوزن
جيدًا ، وسنقوم بذلك معًا
على الرغم من أن الطبيب البيطري أشار إلى  أنا
لست بحاجة إلى خسارة 50 في المائة من
وزن جسدي ، فقد قام
مالكه السابق بتسليم البقع إلى
ريتشموند فيرجينيا لرعاية الحيوان
والتحكم ، وهو أكبر غطاء
واجهه الملجأ على الإطلاق ، وطرحه للتبني
واصفاً جسده بأنه شره.
فاز K Ford بالحق في أخذ Patches إلى
المنزل ، فقد استغرق الأمر اثنين لحمل قفصه بعد أن
كتبت أنها تريد الذهاب في رحلة
إنقاص الوزن.
ركب أحد المعجبين بشكل مريح على صفحة Facebook الخاصة بـ Patch ،
وأريد بشدة أن أضع وجهي
في بطنه ، وقد أنشأ الآخرون الميمات
مثل مواء nalisa بعد
الأسبوع الأول ، شكرًا لك Kay وقد ارتبطت البقع ،
فماذا لو لم يتمكن من الدخول إلى
الباب؟  سرير القط ، سيكون
في النهاية على ما يرام عزيزي ، أنا لا
أضحك عليك ، المحطة الأولى في
العملية ، إنقاص الوزن ، كانت رحلة إلى
بقع الطبيب البيطري تخسيس بالفعل
38.8 حسنًا ، هذه الاختبارات الرائعة تشير إلى أنه
لا يوجد شيء خاطئ في أن النظام الغذائي والتمارين
الرياضية لن  إصلاح القط يزن خمسة
أضعاف وزن يوركشاير تيريير من K
عندما يتعلق الأمر بأهداف إنقاص الوزن ، دعنا
نقول بعد عام من الآن يقول لك أحدهم
ما هو الهرة الجديد ماذا تأمل أن
تكون قادرًا على القول
إنني أحب هذا الهرة الجديد
للبقع a 20  خسارة وزن باوند ،
وأود بالتأكيد أن أقول الشيء نفسه
الذي سيجعلها مقلدة
[موسيقى]
مضحكة قالت كيت نفس الشيء في
اللحظة الأولى التي وضعت أعينها على البقع يا
جيني معظم سي إن إن
نيويورك